Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We are back!
And in this episode, we shall talk about auxetic
materials.
Auxetic materials are materials that when
stretched, thicken perpendicular to the direction
we're stretching them.
In other words, instead of thinning, they
get fatter when stretched.
Really boggles the mind, right?
They are excellent at energy absorption and
resisting fracture, and are therefore widely
used in body armor design, and I've read a
research paper stating that even our tendons
also show auxetic behavior.
These auxetic patterns can be cut out from
a number of different materials, and are also
used in footwear design and actuated electronic
materials.
However, all of these applications are restricted
to rather limited shapes.
Furthermore, even the simplest objects, like
this sphere cannot be always approximated
by inextensible materials.
However, if we remove parts of this surface
in a smart way, this inextensible material
becomes auxetic, and can approximate not only
these rudimentary objects, but much more complicated
shapes as well.
However, achieving this is not trivial.
If we try the simplest possible solution,
which would basically be shoving the material
onto a human head like a paperbag, but as
it is aptly demonstrated in these images,
it would be a fruitless endeavor.
This method tries to solve this problem by
flattening the target surface with an operation
that mathematicians like to call a conformal
mapping.
For instance, the world map in our geography
textbooks is also a very astutely designed
conformal mapping from a geoid object, the
Earth, to a 2D plane which can be shown on
a sheet of paper.
However, this mapping has to make sense so
that the information seen on this sheet of
paper actually makes sense in the original
3D domain as well.
This is not trivial to do.
After this mapping, our question is where
the individual points would have to be located
so that they satisfy three conditions:
one: the resulting shape has to approximate
the target shape, for instance, the human
head, as faithfully as possible
two: the construction has to be rigid
three: when we stretch the material, the triangle
cuts have to make sense and not intersect
each other, so huge chasms and degenerate
shapes are to be avoided.
This work is using optimization to obtain
a formidable solution that satisfies these
constraints.
If you remember our earlier episode about
optimization, I said there will be a ton of
examples of that in the series.
This is one fine example of that!
And the results are absolutely amazing - the
possibility of creating a much richer set
of auxetic material designs is now within
the realm of possibility, and I expect that
it will have applications from designing microscopic
materials, to designing better footwear and
leather garments.
And we are definitely just scratching the
surface!
The method supports copper, aluminum, plastic
and leather designs, and I am sure there will
be mind blowing applications that we cannot
even fathom so early in the process.
As an additional selling point, the materials
are also reconfigurable, meaning that from
the same piece of material, we can create
a number of different shapes.
Even non-trivial shapes with holes, such as
a torus, can be created.
Note that in mathematics, the torus is basically
a fancy name for a donut.
A truly fantastic piece of work, definitely
have a look at the paper, it has a lot of
topological calculations, which is an awesome
subfield of mathematics.
And, the authors' presentation video is excellent,
make sure to have a look at that.
Let me know if you have found this episode
understandable, we always get a lot of awesome
feedback and we love reading your comments.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!